[Música]
y pasado enero en moscú y en otras
ciudades rusas las fuerzas
antidisturbios se remitieron contra más
de 11.000 manifestantes que habían
salido a apoyar al opositor encarcelado
alexei naval
[Música]
las intervenciones son duras
golpeado en el piso después de su
detención este hombre deberá pagar 170
euros de multa por haber participado en
las manifestaciones
cuatro meses después pierde su juicio de
apelación ante este tribunal moscovita
lo entrevistamos a la salida de la
audiencia
quiere permanecer anónimo ni siquiera
estaba entre la multitud simplemente
estaba de pie cerca la manifestación yo
lo que más me desconsuelo vine a moscú
para hacer el trabajo que amo y no
quiero perder mi trabajo por esquel
despedida después de haberse inscrito
por internet a una manifestación de
apoyo a alexéi navalni
jana gordo va ahora ex ingeniera de la
administración del metro de moscú
protesta delante de la sede de la
organización
la última vez no había tanta policía me
obligaron a renunciar diciéndome que si
no lo hacían no dejarían funcionar el
metro quienes son quienes son esas
personas que podrían impedir que el
metro de moscú funcione no tengo la
menor idea según el sindicato del metro
de moscú 150 empleados habrían sido
obligados a renunciar a su cargo por
razones arbitrales saben que es ilegal
perseguir a las personas por sus
opiniones políticas
entonces tomaron precauciones
aún así el pasado 21 de abril en moscú
la policía dejó pasar casi sin problema
una marcha de manifestantes que salieron
una vez más a apoyar al ex en aval ni
una semana después un agente llegó a la
casa de la periodista cristinas afro no
va pueden verlo hay muchas cámaras de
video-vigilancia funciona con
reconocimiento facial y graban todo lo
que ocurre son las que permiten
identificar quién participó en las
manifestaciones y después de ser
necesario los agentes van directamente a
la casa de las personas convocada a la
comisaría christina trató de evidenciar
que estaba en la manifestación haciendo
un reportaje la policía insistió en que
yo había participado en la manifestación
y que por haber cometido esa infracción
sería juzgada dos días después de la
manifestación medusa el medio
independiente para el que trabaja
cristina fue declarado un agente
extranjero nos pusieron esa etiqueta de
agente extranjero que para nosotros es
sobre todo un duro golpe financiero
porque nos priva de nuestros
patrocinadores y esa declaración también
pone en peligro nuestra seguridad
los partidarios de alexéi navalni que
están más en la mira corren más riesgos
hola
en este teléfono está conectado a mi
brazalete electrónico
sabe cuál es el perímetro autorizado
para los desplazamientos corresponde al
perímetro de mi apartamento condenada a
dos años de colonia penitenciaria en
2012 tras el primer proceso llamado
político de la rusia de vladimir putin
mashiah alekhina una de las puse y riot
fue asignada a residencia mientras se
realiza su investigación este es mi
balcón
aquí es donde he vivido los últimos tres
meses acusa de haber infringido las
reglas epidemiológica por llamar a
manifestar corre el riesgo de ser
condenada a dos años más de cárcel
es verdad que el juicio de la spu silva
jet fue uno de los juicios represivos
más sonados en la historia de la rusia
moderna muchas personas en el mundo
entero vieron a esos tres jóvenes y
encerradas en un acuario delante de un
tribunal pero hoy en día todo el mundo
se convirtió en esas tres jóvenes lo que
importa no es a cuántas personas han
encarcelado sino entre cuántas personas
han sembrado el miedo pulgar hola a
todos bienvenidos al gran directo y
nóvaya gazeta y/o better info el pasado
6 de mayo aniversario de otra
manifestación que se va
los políticos la ong de info organizó
una transmisión en directo de varias
horas por youtube para sensibilizar la
opinión frente a las represiones jamás
se había detenido a tantas personas
jamás rusia entera había protestado así
para poder expresarse con tanta libertad
por internet estos opositores tuvieron
que superar primero unos obstáculos
técnicos la transmisión no inicia en
youtube aunque todo está funcionando
bien de nuestro lado estamos a 10
minutos del comienzo de esta transmisión
y tratan de sabotear nos es evidente que
son personas que no quieren hacernos un
bien y es posible reducir de manera
lógica quién puede ser las presiones
sobre la oposición ahora son múltiples
cotidianas y omnipresentes lo suficiente
para intimidar a los menos tenaces entre
los que sueñan con una alternativa a
vladimir putin